hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 113 which is
going to be prime am i correct about
that
oh boy i don't know wow all right sorry
it is early and so
it's possible that nobody knows whether
that's prime yet you really have to look
into these things carefully because
there are a lot of ways not to be prime
yeah there are a lot of ways in which
i'm not prepared today well it's it's
it's early in the morning this is an
experiment and we had no choice but to
run this experiment because our son has
commitments elsewhere and uh he is uh he
is the the brains behind the text so
yeah in any case we will much else as
well so much else um yeah so we are
going to uh yeah 213 is prime
113 is prime yeah because i mean it
seems like it would have to be but uh
but i don't know right i just didn't
know you never know sometimes something
that seems like it should be just isn't
exactly yeah exactly
um
all right because uh we are doing this
early uh for those of you who are here
live even though i don't even know if we
told anyone um we appreciate you being
here the chat is as usual uh going on in
odyssey although it's got a longer delay
than usual because we don't have our
usual slate of of of mods
um
shall we just jump right into
i think i think we should jump i mean
there's just so much and you know if we
don't jump we won't get to it
okay
um
okay you want to jump then
um no we got uh we got announcements
right okay yeah
yeah this is this is going to be
interesting today
um
yeah so we are here on youtube and um
the chat is live on odyssey as i said
uh we will be as we have begun doing the
last couple of months posting this video
uh to spotify shortly thereafter we will
be talking a little bit about um
spotify uh today on the show which uh
for which we should all be appreciative
not the fact that we're talking about it
but the fact that it exists and is
standing strong
against uh against
cancel culture basically um
this
you can as we will do a q a today every
we're gonna try to do everything a
little bit quickly here but uh as usual
you can ask questions for the q a at
www.darkhorse
we encourage you to join our patreons uh
this sunday which would usually be the
day after the podcast but in two days is
the private q a for this month where you
can join us on on my patreon and uh and
it's intimate and i was small enough
that you can ask uh that we have the
chat going in a way that we can see it
uh for that so that's that's very nice
we have some products some darkest
products at store.darkhorsepodcast.org
at my substance
naturalselections.substance.com
i've been writing about differences in
competition uh between the differences
in the sexes with regard to competition
for the last couple of weeks and we've
got a couple of
um of covet covert related things coming
up i think i won't say anything more
about that now but uh they're good and i
think actually i may also we're gonna be
talking about the
uh
the trekkers convoy in in canada
truckers for freedom um
that is happening right now that is due
to arrive in ottawa on saturday tomorrow
uh january 28th which is extraordinary
and uh we won't be able to show even
really a substantial fraction of the
kinds of things that are happening there
but i think i will post some of
some of what we've been seeing uh in my
sub stack as well
and again that's
naturalselections.substance.com and as
usual we have three sponsors today for
which we are extremely grateful so
without further ado
uh you are good you are doing number
three tonight the third one you are
doing all right i will prepare you be
prepared okay
our first excuse me
uh today's program is brought to you by
seoul a sustainable orthopedic footwear
company that's s-o-l-e
seoul is one of two footwear sponsors
that we have and we love them both as we
have said many times before we only take
sponsors that we actually
um either have
use ourselves
and can vouch for ourselves or in a
couple of rare cases
because the pride is not something that
we ourselves are in need of we have
asked
a dear friend whom we trust to try them
out and that actually
is a fit for the the second sponsor
today but or the third sponsor uh
someone else whom we love which we'll
get to
so today we have seoul um
footwear a footwear sponsor
our two foot responses are very
different from one another
but both are focused on creating shoes
that help feet get and stay healthy and
people become more mobile our other one
is vevo barefoot which specifically aims
to give you the sense of being barefoot
in your shoes but soul
with both their shoes and their foot
bags brings structure back but with
intention soul aims with its footbed to
return our feet to health and also the
sho the shoes by soul are beautiful
soul has created a foot bed which is one
of their main products it is affordable
customizable and improves people's
everyday foot comfort and they've
created their own recycling program
re-cork to collect and upcycle wine
corks to make its products
millions of customers rave about seoul
and the sole footbeds as well and
two-thirds of soul customers have two or
more pairs of these foot beds our two
bear are two bears we don't have any
bears much to
impress chagrin uh our two boys we have
we have we have boys young men now are
so different it's a little bit the same
but bears don't wear shoes true okay so
our two boys that's hard this is one of
the no this is one of the ways you can
tell we don't have bears um our children
wear shoes uh and if we had bears they
wouldn't our two boys are wearing these
shoes much of the time now they take
some getting used to uh they they tell
us uh the structure under the arch is
unusual but once you get used to them
they provide great support for feet and
again they look great and brett and i
both have pairs too and we really really
like them
so these sole shoes look terrific but if
you're just looking for footbeds to make
shoes you already own be healthier for
your feet try the footbeds try sole
footbeds
also they make a flip-flop that isn't a
flip-flop if you're a fan of a shoe you
can quickly slip on to step outside if
it's wet or dirty but don't want the
downsides of a flip-flop slippery having
a grip with your toes to stay in it then
this is the shoe for you
soul has an amazing offer for first-time
customers so 50 off through your
soul.com darkhorse so you can try seoul
for yourself that's
y-o-u-r-s-o-l-e.com
they're so confident you'll love them
when they all that they also offer a
90-day money-back guarantee it's very
hard to go wrong and this offer is
applicable to all items on the sole
store be it foot beds or footwear
second
sponsor md hearing aid
uh
should i put these in the wrong order
wow i did this was supposed to be our
first sponsor this week
md hearing aid which was also our last
sponsor last week and i don't know what
that predicts about which sponsor it'll
be next week but they do seem to be
cropping up a lot these days
next week's not prime though so
yeah so that changes everything yes of
course it does oh my god
um
so everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
many of us even if we don't experience
hearing loss sometimes need to crank the
volume up on a show beyond what other
people need hearing loss is invisible to
those of us without it md hearing aid
provides a technological solution to
hearing loss a rechargeable hearing aid
that is fda registered and costs a small
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost
md hearing aid was founded by an ent
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but couldn't afford
them so he made his mission to develop a
quality hearing aid that anyone could
afford
they fit so well they aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours and their volt plus model is
water resistant in up to three feet of
water you don't need a prescription or a
doctor's appointment to get one you buy
directly from the source
where audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week
md hearing aid has knocked the price
down on hearing aids by recognizing that
about 95 of people who need a hearing
aid only require a few settings so they
remove some components that are not
needed by most people and they cut out
the middleman
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and this is what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room was
the hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech i wore the md hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voiced man in a room with a lot of white
noise the md hearing aid passed the test
as my conversation partner's voice was
clear and understandable at a price
point of under a thousand dollars i was
amazed at how effective they are
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers and they offer a 45 day risk
free trial with a 100 money back
guarantee so get clinic level care for
80 less with md hearing aid go to md
hearing aid dot com and use promo cord
dark horse to get their buy one get one
299
dollars and 99 cents each when you buy a
pair deal plus they are adding a free
extra charging case 100 value just for
listeners of darkhorse so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use our promo cord
darkhouse or you can even call them at
1-833-772-1392
that's md hearing aid all right our
third sponsor is also
the third ad that we will present today
this third sponsor is sundays a new
favorite of ours sundays is a dry dog
food when they approached us about being
a sponsor we were dubious we have a
labrador labs will eat basically
anything what possible difference was
she going to show in interest between
her usual kibble a widely available
high-end brand and sundays we were wrong
maddie loves the food that sundays makes
seriously she loves it and it is far
better for her than the standard burnt
kibble that companies that comprises
most dried dog food
sundaes is the first and only human
grade air dried dog food combining the
nutrition and taste of all natural human
grade foods
with the ease and zero prep ready to eat
formula sundays is an amazing way to
feed your dog and in a pinch a person
too what do you mean in a pinch
weren't you feeling um were you feeling
a little bit pressured to taste the dog
food when you tasted it as you admitted
the first time we ran out i was feeling
pressured
to taste it having tasted it i was able
to relax and
i don't know about this no longer
feeling it yeah exactly
um i'm glad you read that line
okay well i i'll get back to you on
whether i'm glad i read that one okay um
sundays is easy for humans too no fridge
no prep no clean up no gross wet dog
food smells sunday's is gently air dried
and ready to eat no artificial binders
synthetic additives or
general garbage seriously look at the
label all of sunday's ingredients are
easy to pronounce okay except quinoa and
healthy for dogs to eat
okay
yes that's nothing no as you were in a
pinch go for it yes all right it's
actually quinoa and yes i do know how to
pronounce it
but did you know how it was spelled yes
only because i've tripped over it about
a thousand times sure yeah
uh in a blind taste just think about how
the quechua felt
quechua
in a blind taste test sunday's
outperformed leading competitors 40 to
zero that sounds like a made-up number i
know but here's the thing
when i have a bowl of maddie's previous
food ready for her she uh certainly is
enthusiastic again she's a lab but when
i have a bowl of sundaes ready for her
it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm she bounces and spins and
leaps in anticipation as a result of
things that we did when she was a puppy
to get her really excited so when she's
excited she does that it's a good
indicator
do you want to make your dog happy
with her diet and keep her healthy try
sundays
um
we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35 off your first
order go to
dot com sundays4dogs.com
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s
dot com slash dark horse
use the code or use the code darkhorse
at checkout that's sundaysfordogs.com
forward slash dark horse switch to
sundays and feel good about your about
what you are feeding your dog it is the
best dog food you've ever tasted i swear
woof
okay
[Music]
all right
okay thank you sponsors um
it's a little silly around here yes it's
early it is early
okay
i think you wanted to start
by talking about your week
yeah all right
so
here's the news
i
had coveted i'm virtually certain i had
coveted because i had symptoms that
match covered so
darn well i had the sore throat i had
the runny nose i had a bit of sneezing
um i treated it aggressively i used
ivermectin i used hydroxychloroquine
prescribed by a doctor both of them
and
the experience and all the usual
over-the-counter stuff that we are now
doing which we have talked about yes
and zinc and quercetin and magnesium and
also during that time nac and black seed
oil yep so presumably i was pretty well
equipped d-wise uh iona for wise
all those things were in order and the
experience of kovid was
incredibly mild for me
and it went on for about five days it
was odd in the sense that
usually it basically felt like a light
head cold
and what it was different from a light
head cold in my experience in the sense
that it didn't really change it was like
i had the initial thing of like am i
about to get sick
and then
i did get sick and then it kind of
hovered at that level for five annoying
days
and then it cleared up and actually on
the fourth day
i got fed up with it it didn't wasn't
any different than it had been on the
previous days and i decided to see if i
could ride my bike and actually i
detected no difference in my ability to
ride climb hills and all of that so it
was a very mild somewhat annoying
experience it's a little bizarre because
you didn't expose yourself to anyone
except the people you lived with right
had already who had already had it um
yeah and it was annoying to have
something that felt like a cold and not
do the things now personally i've been
saying for
much longer than there's been kova that
i don't think we treat things like colds
with proper seriousness that we give
each other colds too easily because
society sort of doesn't expect you to
stay away
um but in any case it was frustrating
not to be able to do things like run to
the market to get something when i had
what felt like an extremely light cold
on the other hand not my choice to make
for other people who might contract it
so i did do it
but anyway the
the experience after two years of
dodging
this virus and obviously i probably had
omicron which is clearly uh a different
experience than uh delta and other
previous variants but
um it is interesting after two years of
i believe successfully dodging kovid to
finally have it catch up to me and
have that experience be
uh be what it was
this also means
that as you mentioned all of the family
has now had covid
we're almost certain of this because the
symptoms are such a close match i will
say
you brought home
four you happen to be at a drugstore
when someone happened to make a delivery
of these at-home tests and you brought
home four which was the limit of what
they would sell you
each box contains two tests
we gave them
at various places so yeah
we can talk about this i guess but i
know i i
i think
i would never have sought out these
tests
i happened to be as i wrote about my
substance i would happen to be standing
in line at the point that they showed up
and all these people came spilling into
the store having been waiting for these
things and
the guy in front of me and me in line
just happened to be sort of quote
unquote in the right place at the right
time and frankly i bought them thinking
well we'll save them for when we need
them to prove you know because because
we can't get into a lot of places here
unless you have a negative test or proof
of vaccination and we don't have the
latter
and
they're garbage they're total garbage
and i don't like that they exist and i
don't and so basically um i am
i want nothing to do with this i want
nothing to do with the testing i want
nothing to do with being asked to prove
that i took a test that we aren't even
being told anymore what the rates of
posit of false negatives fall positives
are we aren't even being told like what
the source on these things is and um and
and frankly the you know the the
more the bigger point is
this isn't a big deal right anymore well
but this is no longer a disease it's a
big deal for most people and you know
you could say that about a cold and no
one's gonna gasp and say you're killing
people and you could even say that about
the flu although most people wouldn't
say it quite so strongly about the flu
and in the beginning two years ago 22
months ago
we were saying about and two people who
are saying it's just a flu like no it's
not and it's you know it's it's not it's
different in part because it's been you
know it's it's a franken virus
um but at this point
um with this variant it is far less in
terms of uh how it manifests yeah but i
still want i still want to make this
point okay
eight tests for eight come up negative
in a family in which the people who were
tested were presumed positive
in several cases by doctors by doctors
okay and so my point is look you and i
are who also affirm that the tests are
worthless you and i are biologists right
we are not lab biologists but we have
certainly done lab work right so we are
going to be well above average in our
ability to do the test as the protocol
it wasn't a failure to swab right it was
it wasn't a failure at any level and if
we
did the test in such a way that it did
not come up positive eight times out of
eight because of something in the
technique than it is a flawed test at
that level and if the test is simply so
insensitive that it can't measure these
things how is it possible that we're two
years into these things that we're
distributing these tests without
information about how seriously to take
their results when the tests appear to
be nonsense
second thing is i don't know whether the
lightness of the disease that we faced
was entirely a fact of omicron whether
it was because we have been
very diligent now that we understand the
role that things like vitamin d
deficiency and ionophore deficiency play
to supplement these things we are
extremely careful about this so we were
well prepared but the point is
or the early treatment
or the early treatment or all of the
above and the point is why is the cdc
not recommending the supplementation why
is why are we distributing tests that
give a completely false impression to
the extent that knowledge about whether
you are or aren't positive could be
useful in terms of controlling the
spread of the disease if that's even
what we should be attempting to do with
omicron
right why is the experience of this so
far off of the official recommendation
right why and this is
this is really the crux of the matter is
and by the way if you want to know what
light looked like in every regard the
data stream is polluted in every every
single regard there's nothing that you
can no ability to like there's no place
you can stand and be like okay i'm
limited when i can see there's some
columns i have to look around but at
least i know from here what i can see
about the official counts or
anything you can't trust any of it the
yeah the the officials are blinding
themselves right we can talk all day
about you know adverse events but the
point is they tell us that we can't
trust the data they don't tell us what
we're supposed to infer the level of
adverse events from other than the data
in the very system they aren't doing
autopsies which would be the way if you
were really interested in finding out
whether people who had died in
some temporal proximity to a vaccination
had died from it or just uh it was a
you know a spurious
temporal correlation but we're not
collecting the data so anyway the data
stream is polluted all over the place
but the tell for me yep the tell
is
what happened at the point that omicron
seems to have caught them and everyone
else off guard right at the point that a
variant shows up
which as many of us pointed out has many
of the characteristics that you would
ascribe to an attenuated
virus vaccine as a woman i know
said to me this week who is who does not
particularly follow the podcast or
anything
isn't omicron what we all wanted
well like isn't that what the world was
hoping for back in you know the first
year of covid i will make my usual
caution right attenuated virus vaccines
are the best vaccines from the point of
view of
their interaction with the system that
is to say they properly alert the body
to um to the antigens that the body
becomes sensitive to because they are
actual infections right and so the point
is your body knows how to detect an
infection it detects the infection from
the attenuated virus it has the proper
reaction it makes a durable lasting
immunity right that's what you want it
has a slight danger to it
which is that because you're using an
actual living organism right
organism is i'm using the term loosely
but
right
but nonetheless the point is you're
talking about something that has genetic
information in it and evolves and
basically i would argue it is a living
organism it just borrows all of the
machinery from you but
let's put that aside it's not important
to the question you're talking about
something that can evolve right now it's
very unlikely to evolve because of one
thing
right the one thing is that the
attenuated virus vaccine that we give
you is not contagious which means it has
a very limited window in which to learn
new tricks that might be dangerous to
you right and so the point is even if it
makes slight progress on that question
if it doesn't jump to the next person
that whatever progress it makes is lost
okay
omicron is not like this even though it
has many of the characteristics of
attenuated uh virus vaccines it lacks
some of them it's not as attenuated as
you would want right an attenuated virus
vaccine that's really great will have
effectively no symptoms
this one has symptoms and it's highly
contagious it's highly contagious which
means that what evolves from omicron
yeah could be uh more attenuated than
omicron that's one strong possibility
but it's not the only possibility and so
yes
the universe having delivered omicron to
us at this moment we ought to look at it
and say you know what that is
functioning like a vaccine and we ought
to
pivot our policy on that basis right
we ought not say oh yeah hey a vaccine
because it has this evolving capacity to
it this this policy pivoting you speak
of which
is the amazing fact yes nothing changed
right it was like you could tell right
were they gonna have a meeting and say
you know well in light of omicron does
this booster stuff make any sense you
know geez we don't you know if they're
being honest with themselves and what
they say to us has anything to do with
what they say to themselves which is
clearly not the case but if it did they
would say something like we don't have
any idea what the adverse events are
from here because we don't trust theirs
and there's no other system to collect
them right maybe we shouldn't be
advising boosters because a
what do the boosters have in them they
have the alpha variant uh antigen
or the information to produce that
antigen um and b
there's an adverse event risk they
clearly don't know what it is there's no
reason to give a booster when in fact uh
you know again
they have conflated from the beginning
and i believe that this is a way to fool
the public because the public has some
understanding of what an antibody is
they have conflated
antibodies with immunity which is wrong
right the best immunity the primary
immunity the immunity that you want is t
cell based immunity which doesn't mean
that antibodies are account
yet you can't
it's harder to quantify
and therefore you know the human brain
that craves the reductionist whether or
not it knows it and frankly the less
scientifically literate you are the more
enumerate you are the more likely you
are to crave the simple metric the
simple rubric and to grab onto it and
say yes but you know antibodies
well also if you want to fool people
right then the point is you can say
things like well but the antibody
response to the vaccines is blankety
blank times the response to the
infection itself and the point is you
may even be right but that's not an
indication of its utility that's an
indication that the thing that you've
decided to measure fluctuates wildly
with the presence of the antigens and
yes your body did mount a response right
it mounted a response but it mounted a
response on the b cell side and in any
case the whole thing is
a game and the idea is clearly there are
lots of things that you and the public
um
can't parse and so what you're going to
do is listen for
authorities who are going to say words
like antibodies
you said that as if we're not in the
public none of us can parse
because the data stream is so polluted
we do we simply do not know in fact i'm
gonna
with regard to the tracker's convoy in
canada um
we can see like when it's when it's a
measure of like people showing up to a
thing and there's people on the ground
filming it and then you see radio
silence from media you can say aha bias
right but
because
the only things you can know for sure
with regard to covet are anecdotal
stories of
you know and they might be three four
five degrees of separation deep we're
like well no i heard about this guy who
didn't recover when or did recover after
and you know these sorts of things but
the the aggregate requires
data that we receive from
who you know the who the cdc maybe the
nih none of whom are trustworthy they're
demonstrably untrustworthy
and you know what you're one of the
this is not a silver lining but it's
necessary
um
things
that is happening is that many people
are waking up to the corruption of the
three-letter agencies like the cdc and
the nih and and then asking
what does it mean about the ability of
in the case of those organizations
american
scientists to actually do science
and the answer is
uh a lot
because the vast majority of science
takes money and um cdc is setting policy
for
medically or oriented science and the
nih is funding a vast majority of the
science that at least has any medical
manifestations and um and we just we we
see
that even the belief of you know fauci
who's now said it multiple times um that
to disagree with him is to disagree with
science i can't remember the exact
phrasing attacks on him or attacks on
science and you know
he has a degree in science and day one
of sciencing is that's not how science
works
like
no sir
you are either
far dimmer than you present or much more
likely far more corrupt than anyone is
admitting all right so
the point that i think you and i are now
frustrated by and struggling to make in
a way that it can be heard right you and
i
take science very seriously right down
to the philosophy of science which yes
is a bit dry but if you don't get it
right the stuff you stack on top of it
actually doesn't work it is the
foundation on top of which you build all
of the things that you do in order to
discern what is real in the universe via
the scientific method therefore if your
foundation
is
uh bad then the rest of your science is
bad and if you're if your foundation is
uninvestigated you may get lucky and you
may have you may have built your
scientific
protocols your methods whatever your
research program is on top of something
that actually makes sense but you got
lucky it doesn't it doesn't mean that
that you were doing it right all along
you you need to start with you know
i just i used to hate words like
epistemology and pedagogy but you know
you need to start with the epistemology
you need to start with the assessment
of how it is that we make claims of
truth that's all epistemology means how
you know what you know the philosophy of
trying to understand what it is that you
know what the what what do you mean you
can't because
if you go to a paper the problem is
people say well look here's a paper you
can start that where they're
philosophically who you you if you're
doing the work can do that yes that's
what happens
well but my point is okay well then
we're talking about two different groups
of people okay
scientists must start there yes and they
don't okay but you just said almost no
scientists could but they don't and the
problem is we in the public would love
the idea that oh here's a scientific
paper and it was done with the
scientific method and it tells me that x
you know is causal of y okay so you are
actually i think then arguing that
other scientists
can't even walk into some scientists
communication about what they did and
necessarily tell if they if they
proceeded from hypothesis for instance
because it is
well understood that many many papers
don't even pretend this used when back
when i was invited to do to peer review
papers and i did it
my most frequent critique was
where's the hypothesis how is this
claiming to be science at all they at
some point stopped asking me because i
was constantly saying i don't think this
is hypothesis-driven science therefore i
don't think it's science
um but
but
increasingly you have people claiming
that they started with a hypothesis when
they didn't and they write it into the
paper and it's just a lie well there are
two no there are two levels of this lie
okay one is they actually observed
something in data and they claimed they
came up with a hypothesis second and
then they claimed the hypothesis
preceded the collection of data that is
invalid that is not a scientific test it
is an observation yes it's not a
scientific test but the idea that they
test a hypothesis is
untrue is untrue and therefore it's
actually fraudulent okay but then
there's a second level of fraud i was
just using the word lie right well no
but there's a second level of fraud that
is also rampant here yeah and that is
the conclusion preceded any of it right
and so the point is it's not even an
observation so we wouldn't even be we
wouldn't this paper wouldn't exist had
work been done that somehow falsified
the cherished conclusion that they were
right the conclusion started and there
are a dozen ways to get to it you can
run enough experiments that eventually
one will give you a spurious result that
matches your conclusion and you'll
publish that one you could have no
correlation whatsoever you can run 20
experiments and one of them comes up
statistically significant just because
mathematically that's likely to be the
case sure and you publish that one there
are lots of ways it can happen but the
basic point is if the and everything
everything about the culture of modern
science uh pushes a person towards that
even if they are completely honorable
right if you do ten
experiments and nine of them come out
negative um it's very hard to get those
published yeah now i will point out lots
of people it's hard to get the negative
ones published lots of people who on an
average day are good at this kind of
thinking have screwed it up with covet
right and xkcd is going to be a prime
example here i'm very disappointed in
xkcd and what it was unable to detect in
what in the shenanigans that were going
on but if you go back far enough in xkcd
the green jelly beans yeah the green
jelly bean
cartoon describe it
so basically the idea is um
you've got a bunch of different
hypothesis tests somebody is
running the test at the various
different colors of
what were they were the m ms they're
jelly beans jelly beans right um uh are
related to so did you find it i did but
it's long so it's not going to show up
what is the test against what the what
is the the thing so you can show my
screen zach although you can't see all
of it jelly beans cause acne scientists
investigate but we're god it's so small
um
but we're playing minecraft fine we've
found no link between jelly beans and
acne p greater than .05 that settles
that i hear it's only a certain color
that causes it scientists but minecraft
we found no link between purple jelly
beans and acne p greater than 0.05 we
found a liquid ground jelly beans and
acting etc etc no link between you know
pink blue teal
salmon red
and okay goes on and on and on and on
um
we found a link between green jelly
beans and acne p less than 0.05 whoa
and then they go on fish and then and
then we see
you know they tested whatever that's
going to be 25 colors yeah right
news green jelly beans linked to acne 95
confidence only 5 chance of coincidence
so the point is you know the point the
point is they did
they did 20 tests the point is
statistically significant means
something that people don't understand
what it means and what it means is it is
a tolerable level of risk that something
and uh
our friend dr roligator is going to once
again chastise me
over a subtlety buried in here but um
but the point is it is a tolerable level
of risk that the pattern that you have
observed is not the result of anything
other than sampling error right and the
point is if you set that number to zero
you can't do the science you have to
accept some tiny risk that randomness
will fool you and the point is if you do
a bunch of tests and there's nothing to
be found some of those tests will come
up positive because of this sampling
error issue
so
now you're going to take me well i don't
i don't think it's sampling error but i
don't think we want to get into the
weeds here i don't think sampling errors
is
it's sampling error in the sense that
you have a non-pattern and if you grab a
bunch of handfuls of data some of them
will be skewed because every handful is
non-random or it's random and there's
meta it's like
okay technically technically sampling
but anyway the point is data set
um the point is
we have a test a hypothesis test
on the table a de facto hypothesis test
about what you and i have been
struggling with over the entirety of all
of these live streams over all of our
public work trying to sort out what is
and isn't going on with covid and our
response to it right our point has been
this appears to be conclusion driven yes
okay this appears to have started with
its conclusion and then the facts are
being bent in order to lead us to that
conclusion rather than proceeding from
the evidence to see where it takes us
right that is
not only unscientific it is the inverse
of scientific it's not even open to
discovery right
now that is a terrible accusation right
if that is true it says
utterly dire things about our system
which we have said hey this is utterly
dire and the point is follow the
conclusions follow the anti-science
follow the pied piper omicron is the
test
of this hypothesis right we did not see
omicron coming but the point is
we have been delivered something that is
so radically different from the variance
that preceded it in terms of its
consequence and risk that you would
expect policy to pivot
radically in the aftermath of its
emergence and it didn't pivot what
happened is
you saw a exactly the same scare tactics
right when omicron showed up it was like
scary new variant omicron right when in
fact there were indications from the
beginning that the
the
response to which would be the opposite
actually
maybe this one has a much lower rate of
death which implies a much lower rate of
everything that you know puts people at
risk of death
and so the fact that we are being told
that of course
you know scientists say that the
response to kovid to omicron is that you
should go get your booster right is
evidence that the conclusion started the
booster was the point and then the
circumstances are being um
presented in such a way at so as to
suggest that
same conclusion still follows and that
is a very unsettling thing and i don't
pretend to know uh how you're supposed
to grapple with that discovery that
you've been through two years of
insanity when
and you've been told that the insanity
you were being dragged through was
because scientists had figured stuff out
when in fact it turns out that what they
were doing was completely unscientific
and conclusion driven from the beginning
but that does appear to be the case well
in some
i think you know as i as i've been
saying for many months now i'm really
trying to figure out what's in the heads
of the of the true believers here
and i think one of the things that you
know the true believers
you know and some of the some of the
true believers don't believe all of it
anymore you know they're seeing cracks
in the in the public narrative but they
still they still believe some of it like
you know most of the people who are now
seeking this middle ground and um saying
okay enough already
still believe fervently with a like a
religion like fervor in for instance the
vaccines
and uh you know i see people saying
things like i was
i was so relieved i cried tears of joy
the day i got my first vaccine
covet vaccine
and i think wow you know how how do you
how would you
sort of back away from that edge then
how how would you recover your own sense
of sort of rationality and dispassionate
analysis
if
you were that emotional if you believed
the story to such a degree
that at the point that it was announced
that there would be vaccines at some
point and then it was still months away
and you were promised and promised and
promised as soon as you get this and as
soon as enough of your fellow people get
it then you get your life back
and you believed to such a degree that
you were you and you were also scared
you were you're gonna get your life back
both in terms of being able to do all
the things but also um you don't have to
be scared about dying anymore
and
you get it and then it turns out well it
doesn't really reduce transmission and
it's not really that effective and um
and it's not even all that safe and all
of these things and you you cannot you
cannot back away from
really the emotional conclusion that has
now been instantiated in your memory as
i remember i remember the promise i
remember being promised and then having
it delivered and it came to me and here
i am and
who is to blame for this not working out
ah
it's the dirty unvaccinated that's who
is to blame here that is who we shall
blame
and
a lot of the people who are seeking a
middle ground now aren't actively
aren't actively blaming the unvaccinated
but they are also in no way as far as
i've seen actively investigating their
own
frankly
misguided having been
vastly manipulated by media narratives
emotional response that got them to go
all in
on being excited and relieved and
overjoyed at getting that job
yeah
and so they become in some sense
addicted to the relief and the point is
they will they will reinvigorate the
story even as it comes apart in front of
them in order to return to that state of
feeling like they had figured it out and
other people were wrong and you know and
relief was in sight
and you know it's it's sloppy thinking
it in the extreme and it's it's a
disaster um you know people would have
been much better off
with uh frankly simple advice about how
to
you know
deal with their vitamin d deficiency of
course of course they would have so this
um i wanted to get this in while you
were talking earlier but i still do want
to show it
zack this from the oregon health
authority um
tell us how your friends and family
helped you through covet 19.
you have been in bed for two days with a
sore throat and fever you hoped it was
just a regular head cold but as symptoms
persist you recognize the inevitable and
get a test it's cobit 19.
your friends and family are concerned
and want to help what do you need
groceries someone to help with child
care someone to run to the pharmacy for
you or walk the dog
so they're soliciting stories
you've had a sore throat and fever
you have something in the general scheme
of a cold or maybe even a flu depending
on the variant this sort of thing
you recognize the inevitable
they are trying to keep us so scared of
one thing one thing and only one thing
and this you know this again to your
point and this is why i wanted to
interject this many minutes ago
to your point about the narrative will
not shift
imagine soliciting stories about the
cold
you recognize the inevitable
you're gonna be
not feeling up to walking your dog for a
couple of days
what do you do right it's actually
they've loaded you up with a concern and
then the point is yeah even if what you
should be experiencing is
oh this is an annoyance rather than a
life-threatening condition the point is
they're gonna now collect on having
loaded you up with that fear right right
and they're going to instead of letting
you calibrate how how to feel about how
sick you are
they're going to tell you how to feel
and that is you should feel
frightened right
um yes you know that's the other thing
that needs to be said here is
what we experienced with cobit was
super mild i do if people want to know
what that looked like frankly i did a
joint live stream with chris martinson
an experiment that we did where we
streamed to our two channels i was sick
um before we went on camera i mentioned
this to chris and he said yeah i hear it
in your voice so you can go there you
can hear it right you can see exactly
what it looked like and how debilitating
it was
i will say uh of all of us toby actually
uh defeated the thing in
you know less than 24 hours of you know
sniffles and sneezes yeah i couldn't
send him to school so he went on a bike
ride right i mean
but but it was exactly the same the sore
throat you know all exactly the same
symptoms and none of us got new things
from the other as it just progressed
through the face right and so we all had
the same thing if you didn't have a
whatever you know
nightmare of a public health authority
out there we would be having a very
different conversation and the
conversation would sound like okay
omicron is sweeping through the
population
it is folly to think that we can control
it right this is so contagious that it's
uncontrollable we ought to protect those
who are vulnerable and there is
presumably an age threat stratification
in the danger of this thing so i may
have had something that felt like a mild
cold an 85 year old might have something
very different we should protect people
from it you know even though it's not
that people can't die from this right
but you know the fact is the nature of
death is such that you you you know you
become fragile and more vulnerable to it
and at some point you're so vulnerable
that nearly anything can push you over
so
turning society upside down doesn't make
any sense so the right conversation to
be having is
in light of omicron
the policy auto radically shift in the
direction of we can't control this we
should protect the vulnerable we should
go back we should rescue our economy to
the extent that we can still
do it we should address our supply chain
issues and if something evolves from
this that has some different pattern
we'll get back to you we'll look at that
one then and we'll say what does it
suggest that we should be doing but of
course we're not having that discussion
and that tells you everything you need
to know
um and aside so there's a lot of things
i think we're not going to get to today
that i wanted to talk about but um you
mentioned supply chain issues and
bizarrely and i've told you this um you
can't get mint
fresh mint in portland for many weeks
now
uh and i found it once
a week and a half ago or so i've been to
five different markets repeatedly
and i've asked them and they and
yesterday someone said
supply chain like okay
you've got rosemary
you got time
what's up with the mint that's not an
answer uh so
they're just and
our shelves aren't empty like we're
seeing pictures of in some places
but there are
a number of things that are not being
discussed or explained
that are happening and
um i would encourage people just to
start noticing those incongruities that
feel like if this had happened
anything more than two years ago you
would have been
very surprised and maybe just start
keeping track
i agree with your point i happen to
think with mint it's demand side
really yeah it's mojitos that's what's
going on is that the level of
consumption of mojitos has gone way up
because as people become anxious and
realize that their government is failing
all around them and the things that it's
you know the supply chain issues with
respect to staples right
are causing people to consume mojitos so
as to worry less that's i think when
people are that concerned they don't
pause to make cocktails they just drink
right out of the bottle
um okay but then they chase them with
mint that that's a you know it's a it's
a it's not a poor man's mojito but it's
somebody who's pressed for time that's i
don't think this is your best work
[Laughter]
all right i think that's that's how we
deliver critique in this household um
it's very very it's hard no gold star
for you yeah not this no no not this
time all right i will work on it yeah um
maybe a mojito spray
no no okay um
before we talk a little bit about the
truckers the the truckers convoy the
truckers for freedom which is
extraordinary is actually one of the
things that's giving me hope it's one of
the few things that's giving me a lot of
hope and it's and they're due to arrive
in ottawa
uh tomorrow i think um but i wanted to
share a couple of articles that were
published in uh tablet recently um
tablet which is increasingly becoming a
a place where you know it's just
extraordinary i don't know increasingly
i am increasingly finding uh that it is
a place where i am finding really uh
really excellent
reporting and storytelling and so this
first one zach
was published actually um ten days ago
the four questions of the pandemic after
almost two years of living with cover 19
we need to ask ourselves about what
risks we're willing to take as a
community by dan ayn
so um he's the first paragraph like many
other pulpit rabbis i found myself in
march 2020 facing a lot of unknowns so
he's a rabbi in san francisco
who was uh you know did not did not
um
did not see his congregation for a while
um and
the whole essay is excellent and i
recommend it but i wanted to read just
he asks four questions
here and i want to ask i want to
repeat one of them in his answer
what responsibility do we have as a
religious community to assist people in
alleviating irrational or
disproportionate anxiety and fears
during times of war social upheaval
community anxiety and concern should the
synagogue not be the place to gather in
solace for a hug a respite from work
life a place to take in a moment of
sweet prayer what is the risk of not
having that
is there more virtue to be found in
spending more time pouring over graphs
of aerosol transmission spread among
low-risk populations than in looking at
the staggering increase in teen suicides
depression mental health crises and
learning loss
just super powerful and i i know
you know we we know some people who are
um
not religious don't have faith not
believers who are looking
um for exactly this for places of of
solace
uh where they can go and be around
people and
treat others and be treated with respect
as human beings and
even most places of religious worship
are requiring
um your proof of acts at the door
uh and
um
increasingly i'm hearing many are not
but
uh this this i would ask i would ask all
of us to consider this question that
rabbi ain asks us
and
the
other piece that i wanted to share from
tablet
before you move on from there i just
want to point out another place where
you can detect that what we are doing
has nothing to do with what's good for
our health or what's good for the public
health has to do with the absurd way
that we have dealt with
natural immunity and i believe natural
immunity
we will never know whether it has to do
with the fact that you and i were
shouting about natural immunity for many
many months
i suspect we contributed to the
awareness of it but
nonetheless natural immunity has finally
dawned on people but it is frequently
presented in the context of
the comparison to the vaccines etc etc
what we don't understand and you know
omicron has changed the picture a little
bit because there are a certain number
of reinfections but
the
fact of some huge fraction of the
population for whom the pandemic is no
longer a direct threat
irrespective of how much risk they face
to begin with the fact that they got it
got through it means that those people
you know to the extent that we have
people isolated
right
maybe we have old people isolated
because they can't afford to get it but
you know who can non-isolate them people
in their religious communities for
example who've had covid right there are
plenty of solutions and the idea that
what you're going to do is hand down
from the federal government some
dictat that results in a religious
community effectively you know turning
into a two-tiered society and not
doing anything rational from the point
of view of protecting the elderly
because really what you're doing is just
deciding who was compliant with a
vaccine that does not prevent
contraction or transmission of the
disease does not reduce viral load
it's it's an incredible waste of an
opportunity the opportunity cost of not
doing the rational thing was
incalculable
so anyway that yes the idea that the
religious community has a purpose that
its purpose couldn't possibly be more
important than in a moment like this and
that we are going to hobble that entity
rather than do something rational rather
than come up with an actual test that
lets us figure out who does have natural
immunity and get on with
life yeah no and i think um
many liberals
uh you know again of which we are too
um
take pride in our secularism
and uh it has been i mean this is
something we've talked about for decades
and we write about in hunter-gatherer's
guide
um but you know religion
has a purpose
and those who are religious
have historically done far better for
themselves and their families than those
who have not been
and so the very smug
position of many secular liberals
that if you are religious you have
demonstrated that you're not educated or
you're um not smart
uh or
you you don't believe in science
uh is frankly an ideological position
that itself is uninvestigated it's one
of these conclusions that many people on
the left have accepted without further
thinking through what it actually means
so
um you know what what is you know what
are some of the values of religion
it's not just about believing in a god
by any means and i mean i remember
hearing this
hearing that from religious scholars at
evergreen actually and it was shocking
to me you know people who had devoted
their lives and who were themselves
religious
um
devoted their lives to the study of uh
scholar of religious texts and to
understanding what they meant who would
say
um
there you know there are plenty of us
who identify exactly as as i do who
actually will say
it's not about god and there i'm sure
there are others who will disagree with
that conclusion but the idea that the
only way that you can um
you can
discuss religion and its value is to um
is to talk about
to talk about a singular deity is really
an uninvestigated ideological position
that many on the left hold yeah it's a
it's a crazy position yeah i've argued
that the um
the claims about the
way the universe functions that exist in
almost all religions
um
are effectively like the trunk of a tree
right they are a mechanism right is the
trunk of a tree photosynthetic no what
is its purpose to get the leaves of the
tree above leaves that they compete with
to do photosynthesis so the point is it
is a means to an end
but the point of religion is
what it does
and you know we have to be careful with
this because
you know the position i've tried to lay
out be careful because xyla and phloem
are also in the trunk of the tree and
they're delivering nutrients no i mean
xylem and phloem are necessary to get
the business end of the
photosynthetic apparatus connected to
the
the roots and all but
but the point is we have to be careful
because
you can overdraw this message and in
fact what we say in our book is we live
in an environment so radically different
even from the environment that we were
born in yeah the farther back you go to
draw wisdom yes there's some timeless
stuff but much of what exists in these
past compendiums of wisdom
is out of phase with the place we live
and so it's not like we can say look the
point of religion is that it helps you
know how to live it did but it helped
you know how to live in an environment
we don't live in anymore so we have a
new problem but the solution isn't
secularism in the sense that finally
we're over that religious thing the
problem is what do we do now that our
religions aren't quite up to the task of
telling us how to deal with modernity
right
right
right
right
um this other piece from
tablet which was published this week
zach if you'll show my screen
called the dissidents by clayton fox
the sort of sub-headline being a handful
of scientists and doctors who spent the
past two years defending mainstream
public health approaches and scientific
rigor against the pandemic response
bureaucracy
and
you know truth truth up front uh we are
we are featured at the end of this
article and many of the people who you
have had on on dark horse are as well
um but it it really is an excellent sort
of
overview of some of the ways that that
many of us have been
actively talking and thinking about what
you know
the mismatch between
what science is and does and how it must
progress
in order to be science and what it is
that
the vast majority of people are being
told and accepting it seems
from public health authorities and so i
just want to read one paragraph here and
then i will encourage i'll put the link
in the show notes of course and
encourage people to read it
of you know with regard to um the
dissidents you know the group in which
he is including us
he says the terms connotation of
rebellion or revolution has nothing to
do with what these thinkers represent in
their talmudic approach to the pandemic
posing questions of questions and
questions of other questioners they are
instead voices that have sought to
uphold the past 400 years of scientific
tradition and practice rather than
overturn it some of their questions have
been prescient and vindicated others
might appear conspiratorial or extreme
but the main point is that they have
asked and continue to ask questions
while a majority of their peers have
done away with the scientific method or
have been cowed into silence
and you know this again you know
invoking the talmud in a defense of
science should not be surprising to us
what should be surprising to us is that
the people who are invoking science are
actually engaging in religious fervor
yeah and it's very disorienting because
people use heuristics to figure out who
the scientists are and the point is they
see stuff that comforts them which
we've seen
all over the place i mean
um
for example
you know there was this famous
interchange between josh zepps and joe
rogan in which josh steps deployed
some what he thought was
evidence and joe
fumbled it in the moment turned out joe
was right
but nonetheless it became a well-known
thing and josh
to his credit decided to pursue it
further later right um so he said well
look at some level why aren't we just
talking to a cardiologist right and so
the australian whatever authority
provided a cardiologist for him to talk
to he talked to for a half an hour one
cardiologist one cardiologist but the
point is he's reacting to the dissidents
right who have said actually none of
this makes any sense you're talking
about a vaccine that has dangers to the
heart severe dangers and we can get into
what those dangers are but the point is
mccullough is a cardiologist not only a
cardiologist but an incredibly
well-published cardiologist right a
well-respected person who has become
a dissident because his point is none of
this makes any sense and so the fact
that he is on the fringe is because he
was driven there right because his
perspective is so dangerous in light of
how much he clearly understands about
cardiology
so you can't just say well what do the
cardiologists say because they don't
agree right and
i mean it just again we're just going to
come back to the same sort of theme
today uh it reveals that the policy
isn't about what it uh what it claims
to be
i don't know there's there's a lot to a
lot to say there but um you have more no
no i i think i'm i'm there okay um so
we're sort of we're all over the place
here and i've lost i've lost my ability
to go through what we were hoping to go
through
um so maybe we should just talk a little
bit about the trucker's convoy
uh unfortunately because we're doing
this when we are i wasn't able to get
any of the videos i wanted to show to
zach and we won't be able to have a
computer i sent him one okay why don't
we just start with what we set it up
start with that and then i have a few
screenshots and then i want us to talk
about it so um you know the short
short version is and um i assume on any
social media platform um
really if you just if you just search on
truckers it'll start to autofill for you
for now you know autofill is often
downgraded when it does things that the
powers that be don't want
but you'll find either truckers for
freedom truckers for hashtag truckers
for freedom 2022 truckers convoy
2022 uh and basically you've got uh an
incredible number i've seen i've seen a
number of estimates the most usual one
is you know 50 000 trucks maybe
spread across
um
you know a long range across canada
i've seen so many different estimates
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna guess here
um uh
driving
slowly um because there's so many of
them and because it's january and canada
and because they are going through these
towns um so they're heading to ottawa
the the capital and they say that they
will be there uh until uh the insane
canadian policies around things like
mandates and blocking people from
actually getting services unless they
comply with um
with these these ridiculous rules are
are taken down
uh are reversed and as they're going
through these towns and even not in
towns and again you know canada in
january it it ain't easy to be outside
but they've got you know there's just
people lining the roads cheering on the
truckers
while you're talking yeah um
um
so
i also have some okay
so here you can see people are cheering
lining the roads they're
waving canadian flags and banners and uh
what you may or may not be able to see
you'll see it upcoming here every
overpass is full of people cheering
the truckers
on
and you know in some sense they are
circumventing the system that
controls what we know about how other
people feel right so we've had these
this looks like it's not taken from
within the convoy because there's no big
rigs in front of this guy and he's going
pretty fast right so is he ahead of it
as far as you know i don't exactly know
okay um so i am going to i am going to
post either today or tomorrow on my
substitute a bunch of a bunch of these
videos i think yeah that actually do you
know from from within or from the side
from within our overhead i've seen yeah
um it's extremely important it's
obviously hard to capture a convoy this
big you could do it from space maybe
yeah
man that would be great yeah um
so
here
uh oops
i want to show just a few screenshots
here zach from from tweets here we have
justin trudeau the prime minister of
canada back on march 31st 2020 remember
march 31st 2020 things things were
things were getting pretty pretty ugly
yeah it was this is one of these lines i
don't i have not gotten why people keep
invoking yet because it was patently
untrue at the time like this is one of
the things that was just patently untrue
at the time but two weeks to flatten the
curve somehow a lot of people believed
that and um it never looked like that
from where we're sitting but okay this
is back around that era
he says then
while many of us are working from home
there are others who aren't able to do
that like the truck drivers who are
working day and night to make sure
ourselves are stocked so when you can
please hashtag thank a trucker for
everything they're doing and help them
however you can
we will see shortly how trudeau has
changed his position
um here we have from you know right now
this is a nun um holding a sign that
says god bless you convoy truckers free
forever
love this
uh here we have a little bit small again
um
a um
an invitation for january 29 2022 that's
sunday um nationwide business reopening
no more mandates and solidarity with the
truckers convoy to ottawa on january
29th 2022 businesses canada-wide will be
opening their doors at full capacity and
abandoning all restrictions no masks no
vaccine passports no capacity limit and
it should not require to be said but
this is not about being anti-vaccine
this is about being anti-vaccine
mandate anti-vaccine passports needing
vaccines to get into services like
restaurants and and theaters
next one and this is very
very much a match for something you
already said brett but remember they
have made the decision to dismiss child
abuse suicides overdoses domestic
violence seniors dying alone destroyed
economy businesses families friendships
and risk our health for a product that
doesn't work
all to implement a passport
trucker's convoy 2022 and here we have
not my prime minister um but oops sorry
um
justin trudeau oh i managed to
take the i think this is from
two days ago now i think this is from
january 26th
um last night i learned that i have been
exposed to covet 19. my rapid test
result was negative i am following
ottawa health rules and isolating for
five days i feel fine we'll be working
from home stay safe everyone and please
get vaccinated
he's so patently hiding
right and he's so patently hiding from
what he knows in the middle of his
self-imposed quarantine he's a
he's a world leader who got exposed of
course he just got exposed of course he
got exposed to omar kron um during the
you know while omicron is circulating he
is hiding
at the height of the trucker convoy's
power and reach and pretending that
that's not what he's doing pretending
this is about public health if he had
been anything like a leader to this
point you would have to wonder
thank you but um
i don't think we do he's a duplicitous
ken doll
and the fact is this is an obvious ploy
and what's more i can tell you
if
he actually does come down
with covid i assure you he will have the
highest quality early treatments because
of course you know why wouldn't he
maybe for all we know he's on um right
and for those of you
for those of you who may be listening
and thinking what you're still claiming
that these early treatments work well
yes a we've experienced it b we've had
many friends who we have connected with
early treatments at the point they have
become sick and not a one of them has
had it fail
so yes they work but also
as you will find in many places
increasingly you will see it with video
uh tess lori caught andrew hill
admitting that the reason that his
meta-analysis says ivermectin's utility
is questionable is that he was pressured
to say that yeah right so
um anyway it's not in doubt
uh the
what is an early to the efficiency of
efficiency of early so um just to go
back to trudeau though um
who is it duplicitous kendall
which i'm i that's great that's that
seems to be true yes
um
from his self-imposed quarantine he
managed to tweet from you know what must
be you know it must be very hard for him
um
zach if you will show this to all of the
parents out there this is from yesterday
to all the parents out there if you
haven't gotten your kids vaccinated yet
please get that taken care of as soon as
you can it's the best thing you can do
to keep them and those around them safe
right now hashtag kids vaccines day
kids vaccines day what the hell is that
well
um hopefully
prime minister trudeau has followed that
up with if you have questions about the
vaccines that's okay science up first
child health canada sandbox canada are
hosting a town hall tonight that was
last night sorry guys you missed it um
where you can ask your questions there
and get the best available evidence from
canadian healthcare leaders here's the
details so here we go
this is national kids and vaccines day
that was yesterday we all missed it now
this is only in canada
you know our people didn't think of it
um
wait wait wait they put kids and
vaccines day on holocaust remembrance
day
that was yesterday wow
was was that yes january 27th was
holocaust rover instead yes
um
so okay just for those listening the
coven 19 vaccines approved in canada are
safe effective and save lives let's move
the needle pun intended and promote
vaccine confidence to promote the
largest unvaccinated cohort of people in
canada kids
so as so as has been pointed out over
and over and over again as is actually
clear in the crap data that we are
receiving this much is actually
completely clear
the age stratification risk for this
disease
is so incredible
usually you would see a u-curve right
usually for many diseases you would see
old people and young people at greater
risk
and
and uh young adults and middle-aged
adults at relatively low risk
not so for covid not so for covid the
older you are the more at risk you are
from covid
what is
a greater risk for the young in this
case especially young men and boys is
these vaccines
and now not only is the risk greater but
the loss is greater the loss is greater
for kids to the extent that they scar
their hearts with myocarditis you're
talking about living an entire life with
a scarred heart rather than living the
last few decades of life if you were you
know right
50 or 60. the idea of a
one-size-fits-all mandate for everyone
regardless of past exposure regardless
of actual risk due to age regardless of
actual risk due to comorbidities
of you know of both the disease and from
the vaccines
is again
anti-science
this is
not policy based in scientific thinking
it can't be because static conclusions
don't fit with the complexity of a
global pandemic they don't it is
anti-scientific it is not even
unscientific it is anti-scientific to be
recommending this especially in light of
the fact that to the extent that the
vaccines work at all
and they prevent kids from getting
omicron they may be exposing those same
kids to future variants which may not be
so
so safe for healthy kids yes and
the idea that we would expose kids to
future risk and then put those kids as
they grow up in the bind of having to
accept whatever whatever remedy is being
provided by big pharma at that time
rather than allow them to acquire
immunity which they can do cheaply now
which you know i wish that wasn't the
mechanism but it's far better than what
they're being provided the idea
that we are going to
basically you know
use triumphalist language and tell
people you're protecting your child
protecting define protecting from what
right yeah from what are you protecting
them you're you're vaccinating them with
an experimental yes experimental remedy
that is dangerous to them you you are
doing that to protect them from
something that could be as mild as a
cold or milder right and you're not
telling them
to supplement their vitamin d because
they live too far north to make it in
the winter and they're almost certainly
deficient right what kind of upside down
world are we living in
yeah
um i think i'm going to skip almost
everything that i had planned here
because um it's it's we've already been
going for an hour since we finished the
ads and we obviously have some deadlines
here but you had a couple more things i
think that you wanted to talk about
yeah there were a few things i wanted to
talk about um
i guess
we should talk about
um the issue of neil young who i
understand is canceling his subscription
to tablet magazine at this moment
[Laughter]
uh neil young uh
delivering an ultimatum to spotify
um that they could have his music or
they could have joe rogan but not both
and spotify did the right thing and they
said sorry neil and they removed his
music the problem is i think people
don't really get the dimensionality of
the problem right people spend a lot of
time mocking
neil young for you know who's neil young
was a reaction that a lot of people
below a certain age had um and that
became a funny joke um and the fact that
i would i would like to assume and this
is mostly the case for me even um that
that many of the people who are
listening and watching may not actually
know about any of this that you know if
if you weren't paying attention to a
little piece that's possible of social
media and you don't know and frankly
you're probably living a life that is
more in touch with a lot of things that
you'd rather be in touch with but you
know this is important but i don't think
you can assume that this is something
that everyone's been thinking about
well i don't know it's possible that the
slice of the world i was paying
attention to was more obsessed with it
but the fact is
at some level and i've made this
argument and i've been mocked for it my
point is actually at the moment spotify
is the front line of the battle over
free speech and yes you can mock me and
you can say it's not free speech because
spotify isn't the government on the
other hand the surgeon general who very
definitely is the federal government did
suggest that these platforms need to be
censoring joe rogan so that is a first
amendment issue in the you know
narrowest and most obvious sense of that
term
and you have also made the argument as
as have others that
our social media platforms are the fact
of the public school they are de facto
the public square we have no other
access uh to the internet but to go
through these private on-ramps and
uh you know eric has said it very
clearly he said uh you know if you know
free speech doesn't mean anything if it
doesn't apply uh in this realm anyway
there's a lot of ways to view it but the
point is
free speech is a principle
the free exchange of ideas is
fundamental to the free west and to the
extent that we are losing that right
whether or not you can justify it in a
court we are losing something on which
our system fundamentally depends and
what people are not understanding about
this battle is that it has nothing to do
with neil young and the comparison
between neil young and joe rogan the
point is this is the last line of
defense
why are they going after spotify they're
going after spotify because as long as
joe rogan is on spotify and he can bring
the dissident doctors to the world
through spotify they can't plug the leak
in their story right so the point is we
should expect the pressure on spotify to
go up and we should expect the pressure
on substack to go up and the point is
you will remember some of you will
remember that we coined a term or a
phrase and the phrase was zero is a
special number and what that means is as
long as you have one place where the
good journalists who remain on earth can
go and publish their stuff as long as
you have one place where joe rogan can
distribute his podcast and anybody can
watch it they cannot maintain their
garbage narrative therefore
you can be certain
that they will go after those last
remaining venues and what they will do
is they will they will ratchet up the
economic pressure on those venues until
they cave at which point they will reach
the state
of zero where there is no place for
those things to be distributed and that
will be a very different world so we
need to get serious about this question
i would say and i have been trying to
induce people on twitter to recognize
that every time they trend some hashtag
that is designed to make spotify quake
in its boots that it's about to lose
some important part of its business
because people are fleeing as a result
of joe rogan talking to doctors on his
podcast
we need
to mount a response right we need to
have something trend that says
thank you spotify and thanks joe rogan
or something akin to that so that people
are aware that actually there's a
tremendous amount of support for keeping
that channel open
and
i don't know how it is
that we
ensure that we win this battle but i
know that we have no choice but to win
this battle because a world in which
there is no sub stack and there is no
spotify in which the dissidents can
still speak to us is a much
much worse world it is a world in which
we will have a much harder time uh
turning the tide against this garbage
to this point actually i forgot one
thing i wanted to say with regard to the
trekkers convoy and i think it actually
fits in really well here
uh if you would show my screen zack i
just went to two of the biggest
newspapers in the u.s
to see what the coverage you know you go
to you go to social media and um again
you plug in truckers and you immediately
get all sorts of stuff and it it
suggests all the all the hashtags um but
observe what happens when i plug in
truckers on
the new york times
we have
from january 19th facing a shortage of
truck drivers pilot program turns to
teenagers
from january 14th super load lumbers
across pennsylvania
two lanes wide and as big as two wheels
these carbon spewing vehicles must be
stopped and then the fourth most recent
one is from december 20th of last year a
holiday feast cooked in the cab of a
truck
so which is to say nothing right and if
i you know if i do trekkers convoy
um
i get 1966 1971 2008 wow nothing okay
that's amazing so let's try wapo let's
try washington post
um
that's not actually how you spell
truckers
truckers results in
um
[Music]
let's see no go away
uh
from september 2021 perspective the key
to the longevity of the drive-by trucker
is oops that's a rock band
uh and from again september
uh no this is from may 22nd 2020 at a
busy east african border testing
truckers created perfect conditions for
coronavirus to spread
and again from may 2020 truckers blast
horns near white house to protest low
rates during pandemic
that is that is amazing
yeah that is amazing um and when you
plug in
just one more thing can you keep my
screen on this thank you um when you
plug in trucker's convoy uh again you
get nothing the most recent things from
2016
uh about putin and i bet so that's
that's it right so that's the new york
times the washington post and i'm sure
that i could just keep going right and
if nothing if you did zero is a special
zero is a special number if you did the
opposite search if you searched for
the public health authorities like if
you were to plug in mother truckers
right then
you would i'm sure get a lot of results
um yeah i think the title this should be
[Laughter]
mother trekkers and what kind of kendall
did you call him uh duplicitous was that
right
but he evaded the other he's not
decrepit
right no he's not a decrepit clown he's
a duplicitous scandal duplicitous
kendall is what that man is all right so
actually before we did you have more
we're good so uh before we close out
this section let's um
zach will you put up uh
chelsea clinton's tweet here
oh boy well actually hold on a second
let me let me set this up oh actually i
think you showed me this i have a link
we got it um so don't put it up yet the
point i wanted to say
we have a philosophical problem people
frequently talk about um being on the
right side of history and others have
complained mercilessly about this term
and i actually will defend the term i
think the idea of the right side of
history is a vital idea right that you
um
you should always be seeking to figure
out wh the problem is that we identify
the right side of history in retrospect
and when we say come to the right side
of history we are making an assertion
about the fact that ours will be viewed
in retrospect as the right side of
history and i believe it is a proper
exercise that gets abused regularly and
the problem is how do you recognize in
real time and it's in fact difficult
sometimes to recognize the right side of
history but i'm going to posit
that there is a method that we can
develop that involves a first step that
is very clear which is to identify the
wrong side of history which is easily
done because they're always shouting for
censorship right censorship that's good
the powerful do
when their arguments cannot stand up to
competition in a marketplace of ideas
right they call for censorship of the
opposition and so if you would now show
this tweet from chelsea clinton
all right i cannot read it from there
um
chelsea she's quote tweeting a guardian
article
quote tweeting a guardian article says
anti-vaxx grift going strong why is sub
stack facilitating science denialist
ability to profit from destructive lies
and
comfortable uh
can you read that comfortable she
probably means comfortably profiting
themselves comfortable comfortably
profiting themselves auntie uh so anyway
and she
the headline of the guardian article
that she's linked to is anti-vaxxers
making at least 2.5 million dollars a
year from publishing on sub stack
right now of course
what the hell does she mean anti-vaxxers
right is she calling robert malone an
anti-vaxxer who is a factory
vaccinologist right i mean the point is
it's a garbage epithet who the hell is
chelsea clinton to be making this point
right chelsea clinton uh
you know obviously
was born into great power right and she
is now
wagging her finger at people making
money on substance some of whom have
lost their jobs for standing up for the
right thing i mean this is so absurd
this is this is power shouting down
truth and frustrated that because there
is a special number that they are
entitled to reach it and reach it by
getting substack to back away from its
commitment to free speech so in any case
um finding the right side of history may
be difficult finding the wrong side of
history is surprisingly easy because in
general the people on the wrong side are
shouting to censor the others so
yeah
that's it
well um
next week we'll be back at our normal
time i believe and maybe we'll talk a
little bit about what we see as the
two-tiered society that is being created
and and about things related to that but
i think um
it is probably time to sign off at this
point yes
one last thing before logistics um i
received an email
uh from someone in canada who is trying
uh
trying to get uh let me say i don't have
time to read the whole email but um
i'm canadian and i've reached out to
various politicians about the absence of
early treatment preventative measures
like vitamin d and lack of health care
workers
and this person has sent a number of
scientific documents to the federal
standing committee on health
and has heard back from the federal
standing the clerk of the federal state
committee on health has said well they
can't share any links to the protocols
of the studies because they're not in
both french and english so this is
bureaucratis uh in canada that could not
be pulled in in the united states and i
am just going to put that out there that
um
um you know this person is fluent but
not fluent enough to be translating
french english scientific papers into
french and um if
if any of the listeners
have that capacity or know of someone
and they there's no there's no money for
it unfortunately um you can email our
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com and the
moderator will put um you in touch with
the person who contacted me awesome um
all right i have a final thought before
we before we go close out it's a quick
one but i think it might be important
and the thought is this
you can't spell masculine without almost
spelling masculine
that's it
i feel like i should have shown the
video of the musician playing for a wild
fox who loves music given that she just
put some sort of trippy visuals over it
uh
yep maybe next time yeah
um okay uh we will we will take a break
and come back as soon as we can uh 15
minutes ish uh with our live q a you can
ask your questions at
www.darkwaysubmissions.com
again any logistical questions that you
have including if you
have a lead on a possible
french translator for some scientific
documents to darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com uh once again my patreon on
sunday at 11am pacific we have our
monthly private two-hour q a the
questions have already been asked but um
we keep the chat visible for that and we
interact and often we go we go
considerably off script not that we have
a script but um even farther than you
might expect um
we go farther from the script that we do
not have further further from yeah the
script we don't have um here's our book
hunter gathers guide to the 21st century
we
continue to be so pleased with the with
the sales that are happening but um
but if you haven't picked it up yet do
so um and again it's available um
everywhere now finally it's in its i
think fifth or sixth printing and also
many libraries have it to have many
copies
and without further ado be good to the
ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]
you